now to an horrific train crash this one
in India over the weekend it killed
close to 300 people 275 as a toll there
now families are demanding answers here
a warning for you this story contains
very disturbing images Holly Williams
has our report
a trail of Carnage extending hundreds of
yards down the tracks the survivors of
this nightmare cruel to safety through
Twisted Metal the express passenger
train was traveling at around 80 miles
an hour when it slammed into a
stationary freight train derailing
multiple cars before striking a second
passenger train it's India's worst rail
disaster this Century officials say it
was probably a signal failure and many
people are angry the country has a
massive rail network relied on by over
20 million passengers a day
families are still searching for their
loved ones a grim troll through the
morgue
this man lost his brother newly married
and with a young son
I haven't told our mother he says she
won't be able to handle this news
and for some the search has so far been
fruitless
my husband has not been found yet said
this woman my husband has not been found
for CBS mornings Holly Williams London
utterly utterly heartbreaking yeah you
don't understand the language but you
did understand the pain
and you could see it yeah terrible
terrible story